[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 conmigo está ya en el estudio
lista como todas las mañanas rosa pérez
masdéu sin falta y nuestra cita
habríamos entonces esta revista de
prensa rosa con un tema de colombia
publicado en mutante punto org que forma
parte de un proyecto en el que
participaron también distintos medios
latinoamericanos se llama hablemos de
aborto una conversación digital sobre
los efectos sociales de la
criminalización del aborto en nuestra
región rosa pero nos vamos a centrar en
esta pieza dedicada a la situación
particular de colombia relatos y trabas
para acceder a un aborto libre en ese
país el artículo lo hizo natalia herrera
durán rosa buenos días raúl exactamente
y si te parece antes de adentrarnos en
este profundo reportaje repasemos cuál
es el marco legal del aborto aquí en
colombia recordemos que desde el 22 de
febrero de este mismo año 2022 está
despenalizado el aborto en todos los
casos durante las primeras 24 semanas de
gestación un período por el que por lo
tanto se debería poder acceder
libremente a este procedimiento sin
obstáculos y a partir de esta semana de
la semana 24 entra en vigor se rige el
aborto bajo el sistema de tres causales
en vigencia desde 2006 que permite el
aborto siempre y cuando el embarazo sea
consecuencia de una violación siempre y
cuando el embarazo comporte problemas de
salud tanto física como psicológica para
la mujer o que el feto tenga
malformaciones graves que hagan pues
inviable su vida así es rosa pero sin
embargo a pesar de todo este marco legal
que usted te acaba de explicar el acceso
libre la interrupción del embarazo
máster automático exactamente y este
relato este reportaje se centra en gran
parte en lo que cuentan las
profesionales de mesa por la vida y la
salud de las mujeres una organización
que desde 1998 lucha por defender los
derechos de las mujeres entre ellos los
derechos reproductivos y carolina
triviño una abogada de esta organización
comenta que desde que se despenalizó el
aborto en este 22
pues 52 mujeres han acudido a esta
organización para pedir la interrupción
del embarazo en el sistema público
después de haberse encontrado con muchos
obstáculos unos obstáculos que según
esta abogada son los mismos que antes de
esta sentencia por un lado dice el abuso
de la objeción de conciencia por parte
de muchos profesionales y por otro lado
esta brecha de clase y también
geográfica rural urbana y es que es
mucho más fácil acceder al aborto en las
zonas urbanas en grandes ciudades que no
en territorios rurales y por otro lado
raúl esto pues ya lo sabemos no siempre
que uno tiene recursos económicos es más
fácil conseguir las cosas como puedes
conseguir interrumpir el embarazo en
condiciones más seguras o incluso fuera
del país mientras que las mujeres sin
recursos deben someterse si quieren
abortar en muchos casos pues
procedimientos clandestinos y muy
peligrosos de hecho nos dice este texto
que según el instituto guttmacher
400.000 abortos clandestinos tuvieron
lugar en 2021 aquí en colombia y que
este mismo año hubo mil doscientos
veinte nacimientos de madres niñas de
entre 10 y 14 años raúl claramente pues
niñas que no eran de clases altas y
según fidel antonio moral es uno de los
primeros profesionales en practicar el
aborto llegar aquí en colombia desde
2006 dice ese inframundo sigue generando
año tras año alrededor de 70 muertes de
mujeres y 100 mil atenciones urgentes
registradas por complicaciones de
procedimientos empíricos y uso inseguro
de medicamentos abortivos también nos
dice este texto que unas 400 mujeres por
año son llevadas ante la justicia por
haber abortado y que precisamente rosa
particularmente este reportaje cuenta
con los relatos de tres mujeres sobre
sus experiencias al buscar interrumpir
su embarazo esto tras el fallo del
acuerdo el pasado 22 de febrero
exactamente y la primera mujer que
cuenta su experiencia sin dar su nombre
dice que finalmente pudo acceder al
aborto pero tras pagar un millón 700 mil
pesos raúl lo que es más de 1.5 salarios
mínimos aquí en colon y que la psicóloga
que la atendió en el proceso le dijo que
si no quería tener hijos que se ligará
las trompas de una vez otra segunda
mujer el médico general al que acudió en
una primera instancia le negó la
activación del proceso y le dijo que
empezará a controlar pues a tomar
controles prenatales porque esa norma se
iba a caer mientras que la mesa esta
organización puso una queja y finalmente
esta mujer pudo acceder al aborto pero
con una dilación de cuatro semanas el
último caso es el de una tercera mujer
que desistió tras ser humillada también
por el médico que la atendió que en el
consultorio le dijo pero si su madre no
la aborto y raúl para terminar ya con
este reportaje también puedes contar que
los magistrados que votaron a favor de
la despenalización del aborto recibieron
amenazas por parte del grupo criminal
águilas negras también las recibieron
las de la organización causa justa y
concluye este reportaje diciendo que
mientras el aborto ilegal y seguro se
siga enfrentando obstáculos en el
sistema médico y no se aborde con
seriedad una política nacional sobre la
prevención del embarazo no y la
violencia sexual que enfrentan las niñas
el aborto clandestino seguirá siendo una
realidad rosa gracias por toda la
información nos vemos mañana con más
pasamos a saludar a nuestro primer
invitado